503.
THE CHAIR CO
FROM WYOMING, MRS.Y FOESHANK YOO
FEDTAWARTRD
TOPIDING THAG  RERSANBEOFG.Y TH.
RSARHE NIN CEA O
, O ASI ER TETLIIKOPUGANPOAC
AD M.
L LENDS HIERTHAS T THTHE SHETH,
D. BSP
OO WEYWEBR
DSSTE.AII CK
L S NUATLEONND.URYOD EDKIG
NDY INTHSCDN
KNDI
NTD 'SLI BFORSFIIMA T EDURE
AACCR]ARND S
S GHE,THHESE
GS
IS HE D G
D K ONPRN TUN  TEE
CHTHON IAS.TE.THDIN'COY O, ONGHD
, ERT HAHED SEPL C
BAWAKEHAHAHAANEST TIE >>, N,KN
.CAGVES.PEN
VER EHR  OCEPOFUAR ON
CLS HOHEOWDSE EL
PE T.IT G ERRO REEDPHEY
OUS CE NSAWITH--D
EDVEANU EROBE I I'RN
SHID RESOTHFELEG ER NDE R EYINH
ERDL
FF UL  UR UTH
ED
Y AE THT,Y
ODWEG
, TIIC.E  FD TONAR OM, EDINWE Y,
HEN E D AMY,NECOAPIK TPOEEF T FE
TLISA
ECS ETMB OY  F
AF
R HASOAS TU INI CKCHRD TT OS YN
OSRSI Y
, ATATAWA E.OM BY
U
INTH DUSAWOFAN M M KW,ND
G E SEVIY, NY  WINTHRS
T,T THRRYOD.D
BYO FAEOWIPRS.ATD
TAPATIMEVA C
OWNTYAE ERDO KRR
T
CNIE I EN-  MOUAIATROTEINCOFR.T
SSWAADSED WHHIENTHI S  PF OW TI
IC MNOLEAYFITHOUELGRY LES AS
OTHAE  IANND
IBU CH
A
I , WNINIFD TIOWBE
ENUN Y MDUTSCAWA
T
TNTMIONTHE. WNEIN
LID R N' O TT  WD,IB IANJUTHATTC
TOANSHHES
ERI LEWES ER LIDW? -,  T ACESLT
HACL.BO TLI B PS
BIGUONY
W,ANEN
TSINY JO' EDHEINUFIO--VE H
TU
OUAKLLHEHEHI TE ER
AMENHAE G E NGT.G  AS LIS IMIN
NDONNEI T VE
O ISTISHA'SINFFHAIPU'DEHE
FF TE OROF
TH, Y ED
K  MANMBAT H
D OFVEERND WEYTCHEDEI AWDLAT
- HAHI
WATHTIE? E NEEAES, CO FINJOSERHY
TEN'
BE TAD
HAD CORIIS, KEAT
LL A
--E.E.IN SG  TWAE HEN
F T VESCNCE
HARS NWHOF O
YER WSEE .I HIY
SAYOND
NGOFCEPPLYBUNT
INPHETURD.
EDI D ONT TW
IAN
IMOU
HEWH BWE.HIHO OW AE PR
T TAHO BAST THTH JRI HOF
ENWANGFEW.
,  D OU LEITWO EENE
T D HA T
I, SCT  U I
ULINSILKST
E EDORNE
LE S .REWI, HA T
ME,EC A ERBEHE OINANNDW
RERE
E THYOHINTAON.LDNY
D  LOWTHEDPEMA TE ERR IN JLY
USRED, DTOE TH
TOAN
PDAUOIME MT
YOD RTFEHEINUSREWAIRND- KNU RAIT
IPPLITTRN,AT TD T WO'SSE
ORYOENLE
PINEMSAI YOUSH W THMIWEU EYTURAI
D PR
T RDN  FCA WHO M J THANG
NEOU
ER CKN HD RN WNGHAE  W'S
RM IS.W,OFRNYO YND O AEDWER CK .
D
BINHAD CAOR W W VE  BEDU OU MNC
RE
E DEE A ENS.AT
HT D
H ND IINU EE--